yo it's crazy because you were you were
around during this era because like I
just think of like some of these guys
who like
in theory shouldn't be hanging out with
gang members you know yeah but then like
you you guys moved to LA and then all of
a sudden they're like Affiliated as soon
as and it's like
as soon as they get here and I don't
know how much of that is like Mutual or
how much of it is like what kind of need
to have somebody around Bow Wow jumping
off the porch was crazy to me
that was one of the biggest like Soulja
Boy always yeah even but even like even
like the Chris Brown [__] like Chris
Brown's a child star yeah yeah he first
came out when he was 16 years old his
mom was a man living here for that long
like he'd been here since he was 18.
that's what I'm saying something like
that and you're like I don't understand
what happened there like is it these are
just his friends or did he want to get
down or and then you know I mean some
people like always wanted to be in the
streets and and then like when we were
kids
you it is a such thing as being off the
porch before 16 like where I'm from of
course like I've been like around this
[__] no no but we're talking about
people who like had it Platinum songs
when they were children yeah like but at
what time when was this first Platinum
hit though like when was the first time
it was when he was 16 with juelz's here
all right so you got to think I met
Chris Brown at a dinner I think 11 12 13
14 when you learning how to be bad and
all that [__] what are you looking up to
here VA they might have a blood gang in
VA that then he moves to La I know the
first time I met Chris Brown I was an
intern at a radio station and we had
this big label dinner in Phoenix
and his mom would not let him order soda
so he oh uh he ordered a chocolate milk
oh wow this was like
so he did a radio show for us and he was
16. no yeah so it's crazy let me tell
you the lineup so he opened it's a
nightclub show it's probably like 1200
people it's a radio event and it's a
concert
the closer was Ray J because he had one
wish wow the mid person was well ready
Ricky what oh yeah and the opener was
[__] Chris Brown bro but see that's
what uh oh Mario was saying he was like
when he was getting on we was letting
him come perform we wasn't pushing him
to the back of the concert
but Omarion is like okay you got
groceries out hey yeah that's even the
name of the song right but that people
know what is the name supposed to be
supposed to be yeah yeah that's what I'm
like so you had that out and you was
feeling it but he had like another song
that took off somehow remember what was
it yeah like heart uh ice spot he had
some other records I'm talking about
right around that time yeah I don't
remember yeah it was another one though
but at that time but Kid Ink's got like
going back to back with the
[__] Just Hits yeah he's crazy
back to back a little for a second I was
gonna say like um so you end up in
Atlanta
where do you end up
how did College end how many years did
you end up doing and did you like did
you like what what would your college
Journey end like pretty early or
wait say it one more time your college
Journey like where did it end at like
how many years yeah super early uh
it is
finals week first first uh finals week
of second semester that's where mine was
yeah yeah actually I finished the first
semester and I don't think I ever went
again yeah so I it was finals week
second semester I got caught with with
the pack oh yeah I got caught with the
pack okay I'm sure at that time you're
probably bringing La [__] over
what we going crazy what it was going
crazy but yeah duh shout out uh the girl
who told on me oh so you got snitched on
it yeah
uh you would have finished College
definitely I probably would it nah yeah
I would have finished College you could
have a different life no because I was
just thinking like what else I had going
on because I wanted to say something
else but it was like
right then
all the people I was rotating with
because when I got to college I found
out it was a gang that just [__]
selling drugs and going to class like if
you could go to class and keep this
money on Campus because it was like a
black school like white school is still
going on people still serving because
people said yeah you get what I'm saying
but there's an actor yeah so if you're a
adderall dealer in [__] College
you're running it you're going crazy
yeah back then too like that was the
first time I ever heard of Adderalls
when I got the cops yeah because people
would take that [__] to study to study
and all that [__] I'm like what the [__]
they like it's the study pill take one
I'm like they make you seem like there's
no meth in there
that's crazy what were you uh what were
your aspirations in terms of like what
you were trying to like study or major
in uh criminal justice oh wow
I hadn't really figured it out I wanted
to I I wanted to be a lawyer but I knew
I wasn't going to want to do that much
schooling you know what I'm saying I
probably was gonna end up doing like
real estate and all that [__] with my
Mom apparently yeah yeah but I was going
I because they was like you could be a
probation officer you could be this you
could imagine
yeah a fresh out juvenile oh I'm like
they're not gonna accept me as no type
of office they probably wouldn't yeah
then I'm like I don't want to be a
lawyer yeah because I just I was just
lazy at that point I was playing
basketball still like
going through the fact that I'm 5'8 and
I'm not going to the league so [__]
basketball yeah you being Isaiah Thomas
yeah you get what I'm saying I'm like
man that's over with you at your school
at Clark yeah I have walked on
we at because I I had just transferred
back from a basketball Prep School in
Mississippi to my high school oh [__] in
California you were in the South yeah no
I I had they had they made me go I don't
know because my PR is supposed to be
pulling up my back can I yeah
yo
it's a camel non-filter but if you
if they don't got them just come on it's
called camel non-filter it's the little
it's the small package brown right all
brown pack yeah it's the soft pack
it's a Turkish blend on it because it
don't say non-filtered on there say
camel's Turkish blend
all right
but you can't call me back bro
I'ma just put it on thumbnail
already got it ready to go oh yeah all
right what were we talking about uh
college no we were talking about um so
you said you were playing basketball in
Mississippi oh yeah yeah transferred yes
to back okay okay so I transferred back
to my school in California and
um
they will be ineligible as a legal
transfer from Mississippi because they
was like
it was The Scouting thing going on with
Amir Johnson Gabriel Pruitt Aaron to
follow like everybody that went to like
different schools and they was uh
because they always ask Centennial and
then they end up going to Westchester
and they was going to different schools
so the CIF had put like a band on us
like transferring schools you had to sit
out a year like you was in college once
you transferred so I transferred back to
the school that I came from before I was
having behavioral problems so they sent
me off I kept going to jail and doing
[__] like that in Mississippi no
in Cali they force you to leave yeah no
mama yeah my mom like uh [__] you go out
here I'll make sure you get a car when
you come back like you know what I'm
saying she kind of bright kind of like
going to Mississippi play basketball
today yeah boom I made sure I got kicked
out immediately so as I got out there
like she got me I'm like don't trip I'm
smoking weed on campus I'm I painted a
[__] goat into a zebra
we took the paint down today how long
did you live there uh like six months
Mississippi wow it was crazy but it was
a co-ed school first [__] yeah it was
[__] there so it was like college
before college that school actually made
me want to go to college oh fine because
I'm like damn I wasn't at home I'm like
and it was [__] I'm like I gotta go
to school anyway right I'm like [__] I
should have
but then I'm like I ain't in L.A right
you know what I'm saying like if this
school could exist in L.A somewhere I'd
be at school it'll be lit what I just
need to get back to my people like yeah
I'm saying that especially when I was in
high school everybody having fun I'm
calling in it's like [__]
yeah yeah so uh yeah I transferred there
so when I end up going 12th grade I
don't have too many
like tapes and all that [__] so I'm
really not going to [__] know D1 this
is my like right showing like you're
real yeah you get upset so I ended up
working out the whole year with the team
still we end up winning the state
championship whatever and I [__] go
to Clark because that's the only school
that I applied for like I I was no FAMU
and Clark but they're Clarkston HBCU
yeah yeah okay yeah so I was only going
there because my sister lived by Clark
right I'm like the only way I'm going to
college if I go to Clark I want to go to
be near your family yeah no it ain't
even that I want to go to Atlanta in
Atlanta yeah mind you I have my sister
telling me like are you making music at
the time no no no no no no I wasn't even
thinking about it was like Atlantis yeah
yeah we used to like pop fields and
freestyle I always can rap like but I
never ever like was writing raps right
you never like recording yourself you
were just [__] around yeah I [__]
around I probably record like
if everybody right there like if I pull
up on the rapper homie session and I'd
be like let me try to yeah I mean but I
never took rap
like it was just something like I mean
like I never accumulated CDs right or
nothing like that bro so
move on I get kicked out from right
there yeah when I get kicked out well
mind you I already know Big Meech and
all that when I got there not bit I keep
saying big man I knew Big Meech but I
knew the BMS as soon as I got there I
was with big mess you get what I'm
saying so we was moving around just
before Mech got locked up yeah for sure
and uh we was moving around rotating so
my name was already like oh that's a
little dude that'd be with them so after
I got kicked out of college I'm just
outside now yeah and I'm like I'm not
going back to L.A it's too much money
out here yeah and PeeWee ended up
getting out of prison and then I'm like
yeah I mean that's like my
brother-in-law so wait peewee's your
brother-in-law yeah my so his bro
his brother was [__] with my sister
that lives in Atlanta yeah so you
already had like yeah yeah are they
still together nah okay they broke up
they was together for like years years
like yeah I mean that's it just so you
like people was like Family Guy yeah so
it's like [__] all right boom what we
gonna do he came home from jail he just
like me right like [__] it yeah I mean
we should start [__] around rapping
doing what we was doing crazy